Tom Holland has done some crazy things
for a movie whether he's dangling a
hundred feet in the air or backflipping
off the Washington Monument when you
really think about how hard he's pushed
himself it's no wonder he's taken a
year-long break for acting the guy is
seriously dedicated these are the most
intense behind the scenes moments Tom
handled like a boss Tom has one thing
that sets him apart from the other
Spider-Man his impressive Dance and
Gymnastics background this definitely
came in handy when it came to doing his
own stunts for Spider-Man far from home
and I really appreciate that I didn't
break anything Whenever there were any
stunts that were too dangerous for Tom
to do stunt doubles would step in but
Tom still had to get very used to doing
backflips off of trampolines and flying
around on wire for this role but Tom's
scariest stun for this movie would have
to be the time that he and Zendaya were
hoisted 100 feet into the air on a crane
with a body cam strapped to them are you
too good I got you I got you
the only thing protecting them from a
nasty fall were a couple of cardboard
boxes placed for safety they were
dropped and swung in a massive Arc with
Zendaya screaming the whole time never
never doing that again but Tom would
much rather be dangling a hundred feet
in the air than dealing with the mental
strain of the crowded room Tom had a
really hard time separating himself from
his role in the crowded room he said I
was seeing myself in him but in my
personal life Tom had an especially
tough time with this because his
character was based on American criminal
Billy Milligan the first person to be
found guilty for reasons of insanity you
can see why Tom said it had him
exploring certain emotions that I have
definitely never experienced before Tom
even had a meltdown at home when they
were in the middle of filming and he
says that he thought I need to shave my
head because I need to get rid of this
character he didn't do it but you can
tell the kind of stress he was under Tom
said I'm no stranger of the physical
aspects of the job doing the whole
action movie thing but the mental aspect
it really beat me up and it took a long
time for me to recover afterwards to
sort of get back to reality this role
led to him taking a year off from acting
to focus on his mental health which says
a lot considering he didn't even take a
break after doing the stunts for
Uncharted now what would we do without
our work friends Tom got along famously
with his stunt doubles on Uncharted but
that doesn't mean there wasn't friction
behind the scenes but we still think Tom
was pulling his weight you're up mate so
good Tom
excellent and if you'd like to help us
out we'd appreciate it if you could hit
that subscribe button but anyway please
Uncharted I was shooting stunts that are
far bigger than anything I've done
before Tom was hit by that replica car a
total of 17 times flying back
horizontally on wires there would even
be times when Tom was attached to a
spinning box roughly a hundred feet in
the air and then I would basically hang
on until it would throw me off this
segment took them roughly five weeks to
shoot and it was really scary but I
think that level of fear just makes that
scene that much more authentic it's a
good thing Tom's so practiced at working
through his nerves he's gonna need that
for when he needs Jake Gyllenhaal Tom
was a real hero on set for Spider-Man
far from home or at least he became a
hero to Jake Gyllenhaal which may seem
strange considering how nervous mom was
to meet the older actor and what Marvel
do sometimes is they would completely
change the lines overnight Tom's gotten
pretty used to that sort of thing by now
he's even improv with Robert Downey Jr
well on that later but for now let's
just say that Jake wasn't used to it so
Jake was like he was like panicking can
you even imagine how weird a position
Tom found himself in so I found myself
on day one with working with one of my
Idols like it's okay man it's okay like
even Jake was impressed by how well Tom
handled the whole thing it's like he was
me in so many situations according to
Jake he'd been acting like a wooden
board before that talk with Tom and
afterwards he did the scene no problem
from that point forward the two became
fast friends even getting into a fun
little push-up competition on set next
one I'll get the next one but we wonder
if he still misses Robert
so there may be a reason why Tom is more
used to line changes Than Jake he's had
a lot of them working with Robert Downey
Jr Tom said that the long seven-month
audition process for the role of
Spider-Man was horrible but there was
one Saving Grace when Tom showed up to
do his screen test with six other kids
he was surprised to find out that his
scene partner would be Robert can you
imagine a lot of people would fold under
the pressure but not Tom he and Robert
got right to riffing off each other and
the funny thing is that Tom's agent had
told him quote Marvel likes you to learn
the words exactly meaning that he wasn't
allowed to improv but according to Tom
on the first take Downey just completely
changed scene Tom was a little worried
he hadn't gotten the role when he didn't
hear back after six weeks but it all
turned out to be all right Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios said
that Tom was great at keeping up with
Robert off book to some very funny
ad-libs and of course nobody could walk
these water stunts like Tom does all
right now you can't help but feel bad
for Tom when a stunt goes wrong and one
stunt on Spider-Man far from home
definitely didn't go as planned Tom was
rigged to a ratchet which for those of
you who don't know is a machine that Tom
describes as I will Zoom backwards and
slam into a wall at the same time the
onset sfx guy was meant to hit a button
that would dump thousands of gallons
worth of water on Tom and you best
believe they didn't heat the water but
cold showers wasn't all he had to worry
about after a count of three Tom slammed
back into the wall and then all I hear
is the sfx guy go sorry not what you
want to hear and then the water just
went
the wall of water came too late and you
know what that means so we had to do it
a second time luckily the sfx guy hit
the button right the next time but you
can imagine how dazed Tom was after
doing the stunt twice still it was worth
it but it looks great he's been through
works like climbing the Washington
Monument Tom can't even watch this scene
back without feeling sick that was
really him climbing the Washington
Monument or a scale version of it anyway
specific sections of the monument had
been built on a sound stage in Atlanta
so that Tom could crawl up its side with
the use of wires and even backflip off
the top from a safe height but according
to stunt double Chris silcox Tom was
terrified to film the moment where he
had to stop in the Elevator Shaft stunt
coordinator George Cottle needed to talk
Tom through it and quote made sure that
he knew all the different things that he
had to do only then was Tom willing to
do the scene but he had to wear a corset
harness that was so tight he could
actually feel his lunge coming back up
while he was dangling upside down this
was a real problem for Tom because as he
says you're in The Mask if you throw up
you drown since the scene made it in the
movie Tom said it was all worthwhile but
every time I see it I get nauseous
honestly we're impressed that he managed
to keep his American accent through all
that
oh
Tom may have taken his American accent a
little too far he'd worked with dialect
Coach Rick Lipton or as he calls him
Pretty Ricky On multiple movies now
everything from Spider-Man homecoming to
Uncharted he helps me with my accent Tom
considers Rick to be one of his quote
Best mates he's even blamed the fact
that quote Rick wasn't there that day
for the fact that his access went
according to him full English while
filming the sandwich shop scene for
Spider-Man homecoming um and uh with
pickles and can you smoosh it down real
flat thanks Tom said it was so bad they
had to cut it so you don't see my face
as I say hello because my accent was
pure English but Tom's definitely gotten
a lot better at it now he even says I've
been working in an American accent so
much that whenever I tell a story like
at a dinner party I kind of immediately
start speaking in an American accent
because it feels more comfortable well
at this point Tom's even worried that if
he has to act with his natural Accent on
set again it'll be quote a little bit
complicated for me now talk about a
lasting change Tom has pushed himself
through some pretty amazing work whether
he's rifling with the best of them or
getting drenched with thousands of
gallons worth of water still we're glad
to hear that he's taking time off for
his mental health now what would you
have to say is Tom Holland's bravest
behind-the-scenes moment we'd love to
hear what you think so make sure to let
us know down in the comment section